so yeah you had these these older men
around her that she that she manipulated
and a lot of these came from her
childhood her father worked in the State
Department or something and he knew all
of these famous former generals and how
did that because that was the thing that
we would laugh about like we'd look at
her bored I'm talking about the
investment community whatever like okay
who's on the board is it go girly is it
right Michael Moretz is it Doug Leone is
it like whatever famous fact you know
John Doerr and it was like no it's
auntie Kissinger and these other
generals and it's like a general is on
your board or some senile yeah old
diplomat is on your board it makes no
sense so the family connections came in
were a factor in several ways one is
that for a couple years in the late 80s
and early 90s the Holmes family lived in
Woodside California near the Stanford
campus and we're neighbors with the
Draper's Tim Draper yeah and so
Elizabeth and Jesse Draper became
friends Draper's daughter
Tim Draper's daughter Jesse Draper and
Elizabeth were good friends and remained
friends and then when Elizabeth dropped
out of Stanford at 19 in late 2003 the
the first person who cut her a check a
million-dollar check was Tim Draper so
that was a family connection another
family connection was that her father
who indeed had been in government had
spent most of his career in public
service worked for the State Department
USAID had gone to Wesleyan and one of
his best friends at Wesleyan was a
high-ranking official at the World Bank
and that guy knew Don Lucas and
introduced Elizabeth - Don Lucas and Don
Lucas met with her and was impressed by
her lineage namely the fact that she was
a descendant of the Fleischman yeast
dynasty Fleishman East company is a
company that was created in late 1800s
by two Hungarian immigrants and 20 years
later by the turn of the 20th century
the Fleischmann's and and the holmes's
became one of the richest families in
America and all that money was spent
though after generation right as if it
didn't benefit from that no because it
was
was actually made very aware that a of
the the success of these older
generations of the family but also of
the failures of the younger ones namely
her father's grandfather and his father
had really squandered what was left of
the family fortune and so I think she
was very influenced by these stories she
wanted to reclaim that place in society
and that wealth I think that was one of
the things that was going on but in any
case it was his favorite because really
great quote that you had where somebody
asked her in her youth like do you want
to marry the president or something he
said yeah someone asked a relative at a
family gathering when she's nine or ten
asks her you know what do you want to do
when you grow up pretty much the
question everyone has asked when they're
a kid at some point or another and she
says I want to be a billionaire she's
not kidding around you know she's
looking really intent these aren't the
idle words of a child and the relative
says well don't you want to be president
and she says no because I'll have a
billion dollars and so the president
won't want to marry me yeah I'm
completely logical for a ten-year-old to
think this and she really wanted you
know to be a successful entrepreneur
from a young age she wanted to be
wealthy she wanted to reclaim the glory
you know of the the Fleischmann Dinah so
it was like this personal thing and then
she grew up around all this royalty with
some tech royalty certain amount of
entitlement I would think I mean I think
I think she also had good motivations in
that her father as a public servant at
the State Department had helped with
humanitarian efforts and so there were
pictures around the house of him you
know in war-torn countries and you know
he always emphasized to her that she
should live a life of purpose and I
think this became in her mind how do I
become not just rich but do good as I
get rich and biotechnology was an answer
to both get rich in biotechnology and
create a product that will change
medicine that will make people's lives
better
and and that will be good for the good
of humanity